after taking 10 days of vocal rest
I performed three shows last weekend in
Florida
and by the third one I felt terrible
so I went in and got scoped yesterday
and they told me that I re-injured my
vocal cords oh man Morgan Wallen fans
are knocking like this one yes less than
two weeks after he canceled the show
moments before he was scheduled to
appear on stage the country singer has
even more bad news
fans were outraged by the last minute
cancellation in Mississippi with Morgan
telling his followers via social media
that he couldn't perform and needed
vocal rest after losing his voice and
unfortunately he's not healing as fast
as he thought the 29 year old posted the
video to social media informing fans he
needs more rest and that he can't
perform for the next six weeks
what's going on y'all
I'm just gonna go ahead and get straight
to it
I got some bad news for my doctors at
the Vanderbilt voice Center yesterday
after taking 10 days of vocal rest
I performed three shows last weekend in
Florida
and by the third one I felt terrible
so I went in and got scoped yesterday
and they told me that I re-injured my
vocal cords
and that I have vocal fold trauma
their advice is that I go on vocal rest
for six weeks so that's what I'm gonna
do the singer went on to explain that he
and his team are working to reschedule
all the shows he'll miss including his
ACM Awards performance later this week
we're working on rescheduling all the
dates during this time frame
we've almost got that done but some of
them are pending so I'll keep you
updated I won't be able to make these
festivals that I have during this time
frame but we are going to make those
right in next year
[Music]
I won't be able to do the ACM Awards or
the lifting lives of it but y'all make
sure you still go
it's four great cause Morgan concluded
the somber message with a reminder to
fans that without this rest is that he
could end his career
they told me that if I
do this the right way but I'll get back
to 100 percent
and they also said that if I don't
listen and I keep singing and I'll
permanently damage my voice
so for the longevity of my career
this is just the choice I had to make
I hate it
but I love you guys
and I appreciate all the support that
you always give me
and
I'll see you soon and I'll be back
better than ever God bless you every
time around fans seem to be a little
more understanding with some taken to
social media it's Dan Morgan their well
wishes one fan writing on Twitter I'm so
sorry this happened take care of you
first we'll be here when you get back
your music makes me smile on days when I
need it and another thing do what you
need to do for you we will see you when
the doctor says you're good prayers for
your healing foreign